they call you mystic Mac because your  predictions eerily always come true just  to get it straight what is your  prediction for the fight oh I I said  four but I'm that that's me being humble  I don't believe he will even exit the  force round but I'm trying to be humble  here on national TV so I say for pay  inside for an incredible show of  humility I want to say that listen you  know I've been rooting you on for a long  time and I'm gonna make you an offer  right now I had some some shorts made  that I would like you to wear in the  ring on this historic fight they're  being brought to you now and I hope you  agree to wear these I think this is  going to be terrific for everybody I  think  well you can at least wife's going to  Conan yeah but just keep them around we  cross you Conan okay all right  you